-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
You're watching. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news, guys.
This week, in a company memo,
the CEO of Delta Airlines
refused to use the term
Delta variant
and only referred to the virus
by its scientific name.
I guess that explains why pilots
have been saying,
"Welcome aboard. Thank you
for flying B.1.617.2 Airlines."
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, he's afraid that
if he says Delta too many times,
the virus will show up
like Candyman.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he's doing anything he can
to distance Delta
from the variant.
Today, he said, "From now on,
our airline's pronounced
Del-tay."
[ Laughter ]
That's right. Delta is in
a pretty weird situation,
but this is nice --
Another company just released
a message of support.
Watch this.
-We sympathize with
Delta CEO Ed Bastian.
Hang in there.
The only piece of advice
we could offer is to be patient.
And before long, your company
name won't be associated
with something so horrific.
-A message from Ebola Farms
Baked Goods and Treats.
Put a little Ebola in your day.
-Yeah.
Ebola Farms.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?
I love that bread.
-I love Ebola Farms.
-Yeah, that's the best.
And they make bread.
-Yeah. I didn't know that.
I just thought it was a farm.
-Yeah, you'd think
it'd be a bakery.
You think it'd be Ebola Bakery
or something.
-Got a bunch of pretzels,
anything you want.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
Oh, my God.
-Any type of carb?
-Any kind of carb,
any kind of baked bread.
They got strudel.
Oh, delicious. Delicious.
-Oh, strudel.
Guys, get this,
a new report found
that nearly all
U.S. government agencies
are using facial
recognition technology.
[ Audience groaning ]
Americans are like, "Whoa,
I don't want something
scanning my face,"
and then went back
to pulling down their masks
to unlock their phones.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, most U.S.
government agencies
are now using some form of
facial recognition technology.
But unfortunately,
it's having a little trouble
correctly identifying
people's faces,
and some can't even recognize
members of Congress.
I'll show you what I mean.
For example, it thought
Congressman Austin Scott
was the 40-year-old virgin.
[ Laughter ]
See what I mean?
-Wow.
-They're not recognizing --
-Yeah, it's not working right.
-No, it's not working correctly.
Next up,
it thought Congressman
Dean Phillips was Doug Funnie.
-Really?
[ Laughter, applause ]
That's not even a real person.
-What?
-That's a cartoon.
-I know it's a cartoon.
-Wow. This is not
working well at all.
-Can we see that again
just to make sure?
That's --
[ Laughter ]
It's not working.
-Wow, it's not working.
You're right.
-Next, it thought
Congressman Sam Graves
was that carnival game
with the clown face.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it's just
totally not working.
-That's not good at all.
-No, it's not good.
It thought Congressman Don Young
was the owner of Jurassic Park.
[ Laughter ]
That's not even --
It's a movie.
-Oh, my God. Richard --
-It thought
Senator Roger Marshall
was Ross when his teeth
got whitened.
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Laughter ]
That seems ridiculous.
-It thought Congressman Brad
Sherman was George Costanza.
-Wow.
-And...
-Finally, it thought Congressman
Derek Kilmer was Beaker.
And there you go. That's just --
They're working out some kinks.
[ Applause ]
This is a fun story.
I saw that a company
is selling a miniature replica
of the rocket
that took Jeff Bezos to space.
Here it is.
-Boo.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckling ] Oh.
-Yeah. Yep, there it is,
anxiously awaiting
to probe your galaxy.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Seriously, I don't even think
you could show that on OnlyFans.
[ Laughter ]
-You think it's "hard" to get?
-What's that?
-Is it "hard" to get, that --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, a little --
-Little "hard" to get?
-A little bit. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Bet you have a "ball"
playing with that.
Great.
[ Laughter ]
-Think people have a "ball"
playing with it?
-Yeah, fantastic.
Do you think his whole "staff"
got together to --
[ Laughter ]
To get that design down?
-Yeah, congrats to the whole
"staff," yeah, I mean --
-This whole bit is a "fallacy."
[phallus]
Let's move on.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Some entertainment news.
Netflix just released
a documentary --
How can I even tell jokes
after that? I don't know.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-Netflix just released
a documentary
about legendary painter Bob Ross
that claims to show the dark
side of his life and legacy.
It's called "Bob Ross: Happy
Accidents, Betrayal & Greed."
[ Laughter ]
Really, Netflix?
Do we really need this?
-Aw.
-I mean, what's next, "Betty
White: Secret Serial Killer"?
[ Laughter ]
Why?
Hey, get this. I heard about
some grocery stores
in Pennsylvania
that are all dealing with
the same unique issue.
Check this out.
-Police in multiple counties
are investigating thefts
at a grocery store,
because someone is stealing
3-foot-tall
Snoop Dogg bobbleheads.
Police aren't sure
if the thefts are connected.
-When reached for a comment,
Snoop said,
"Stop robbing my bobble,
baby bubba.
[ Laughter ]
Stop robbing my bobble.
Stop robbing my bobble,
baby bubba."
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
And finally -- [ Laughs ]
"Stop robbing my bobble."
-[ Babbling ]
-"Stop robbing my bobble,
baby bubba."
Finally, a video from --
This is funny.
A video from the baggage claim
at a Seattle airport went viral.
It shows a package
of frozen chicken
coming around the carousel...
unwrapped. Look at this thing.
-Oh, my God!
[ People groaning, murmuring ]
-One guy grabbed it
and was like,
"Oh, wait. These aren't
my raw chicken parts.
Mine has a black handle.
Yeah, sorry."
Even worse, the KFC Colonel
saw that and was like,
"Damn, they know
the secret recipe.
We import our wings
through Delta."
It is time
for our latest installment
of "Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Polls ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The first poll I asked you,
"Do you think Kanye
should change his name to 'Ye'?"
[ Laughter ]
50% said, "No."
50% said, "Ye."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next poll asked,
"What was your favorite part
of your summer?"
10% said, "Seeing old friends,"
10% said, "Getting out of town,"
80% said,
"That week and a half
when we didn't
have to wear masks."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I remember that.
This next one asks, "What would
you do if you were on fire?"
60% said, "Stop, drop and roll."
35% said,
"Call someone for help."
5% said, "Film it,
and start the
#ImOnFireChallenge on TikTok."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next one asks,
"What's your favorite thing
about going to Costco?"
15% said, "The prices."
23% said, "The samples."
62% said,
"Flashing my membership card
like I'm in the FBI."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Can I come in?
I'd just like to ask you
a few questions."
This next one asks,
"Do you agree with OnlyFans
reversing its decision
to ban adult material?"
25% said, "Yes."
25% said, "No."
50% said, "I'm sorry.
What was the name of that site?
OnlyFans? Sounds interesting.
I've never heard of it before.
I presume it's for
sports fans, though, right?
Because it's certainly
not a website
that I've ever used
on my credit card.
Ha ha ha."
[ Applause ]
-"I, of course..."
[ Applause continues ]
"I, of course, never
frequent that site, and..."
-"I don't even know what it is."
I don't even know
what human sexuality is.
I'm just watching
my sports games on the TV.
Have you seen
Jeff Bezos' rocket?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's not Jeff Bezos' rocket.
-"Oh, I'm sorry."
-This next one asked,
"What is your favorite Mac?"
10% said, "Book Pro."
10% said, "Book Air."
10% said, "I."
10% said, "And cheese."
[ Light laughter ]
10% said, "Fleetwood."
10% said, "Big."
10% said, " --klemore."
10% said, "-aulay Culkin."
10% said, "Return of the --"
10% said, "Oh, I use Windows."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Interesting.
That was an interesting poll.
This next one asks, "What
are your plans for the fall?"
20% said, "Going to a wedding."
20% said, "Traveling to Europe."
60% said,
"Constantly checking CNN
to see if either of those things
are still allowed."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This last one asked,
"Today is..."
10% said, "Thursday."
90% said, "I haven't known what
day it is since March 2020."
There you go. That's all we have
for "Tonight Show Polls."